what social pressure exists around you
right now what are you referring to also
why did it take you
i don't know how old you are but why did
it take you 59. uh so yeah
yeah why did it take you until you're
54. i imagine that
if this occurred to you when you were in
your late 20s maybe three times then by
the time you're 33 or 35 you would say
okay to heck with it forget what other
people think
well maybe i'm a slow learner maybe i'm
also um you know i do care about what
people i did care about what people
think early on and
you have to understand the entire um
structure of academia uh relies on other
people evaluating your you throughout
the various stages
in order to get tenure you need a
ten year committee to recommend and that
is based on letters that are obtained
from the community at large so you need
to dance to the music of a lot of people
in order to be
sort of tenured uh
and then
the same is true about getting grants
grant support is you know the the
selection committee committees are often
populated by people that are
mainstream and they have their own
agenda and
they don't
welcome innovation as much
and
to me it's still a miracle that the ligo
experiment was funded in the first place
i was told by
important people at the national science
foundation that
nowadays
at present time
the likelihood of it being funded would
have been very small it was the vision
of a few people
a couple of decades ago that pushed it
through
it's really hard to imagine that
nowadays
the national science foundation or other
federal agencies would
receive an advice from the scientific
community to embark on a risky
project of this type and it was not at
all clear that it will reach the
sensitivity necessary
and so you know you're dependent
throughout your career on many people
uh that will approve uh
your your agenda and uh as a result you
develop the mentality of them listening
and and paying attention and not not
deviating too much from the beaten path
and then that that is quite common what
is not common is someone like me that
reaches leadership positions you know i
i've been chair of the astronomy
department at harvard for nine years and
i've chaired many important committees
that someone at that level often
you know
behaves
even more
as a conformist because
uh because of political consideration
um you have to understand it's just like
looking at the
seashells on the beach you know when
when a seashell
first arrives at the beach uh it looks
special and unique it has special color
special shape but as time goes on you
know the waves uh rub
seashells against each other and then
they start to lose their identity and
they start to look like each other and
eventually you end up with c sand
basically pieces of seashells that are
indistinguishable from each other
and that's what happens in academia
you know each in the each individual
researcher starts different
but then you rub against many others and
you end up being indistinguishable from
them
okay when i hear that here's what i'm
thinking there's this it's not a quote
but it's a story from steve jobs and he
said almost the opposite so there it's
obviously a happy middle he said what
you want to do is take people who are
like rocks that are unpolished and then
put them into a rock tumbler because
afterwards they come out like diamonds
so you want to take
intelligent smart people and have them
argue
i can see this
well as long as the argument is accepted
you know as long as it's a la
so if you create an environment where
people are encouraged to challenge each
other to come up with original ideas
to be different
then
that is i completely agree that that
experience of the argument
and exchanges
is helpful but but if on the other hand
you create an environment where you know
the
dominant view where there is a group
thing where the
uh
the folklore of of a field
dominates and anyone that suggests
something different is pushed aside
that is bad and that's what i was
referring to
so if it's geared toward constructing
and also if it's geared toward some goal
yeah if you look for example if you look
for example i mean the ideal example is
the corridor of bellaps you know bellaps
was
established by a corporation and that
has a profit in mind but then in that
corridor they put very creative people
uh and you know some of them ended up
winning the nobel prize there were lots
of inventions that came out of the
corridor of belabs
and so putting a lot of um creative
people
in the same environment and allowing
them
to innovate and giving them an incentive
to innovate
that is the right right right and so i
in that sense i would agree with jobs
that you know putting them next to each
other is beneficial
but if you on the other hand
you put people together and exert
pressure so that you know they do not
deviate
from what everyone else is thinking
that's bad